I thanks very much so I'm going to talk
about p i4 16 937 so what's that it's
one of thousands of USDA soybean lines
are in the public domain and this one
its origin is from a land race in Japan
probably growing on the berms of paddy
not from a particularly drought area but
when planted out in fields in North
Carolina several decades a load it
jumped out it's called what a slow will
tur so when when water is limiting in
the soil this plant wilts a couple days
later okay this is a pretty useful trade
drought is the most important limitation
on crop production and until recently
there are no commercially available
drought addressing seed supplies in in
the US okay but the problem was this has
been it's in the public domain it's been
there for decades and it the soybean
breeders of course I knew about this
they knew it was important but they
didn't know how to make use of it
because they got inconsistent results
when they did breeding and planting it
out so we came in with a competitive
grant from the USDA about 2006 to work
in collaboration with USDA scientists to
try to figure out what is the
physiological basis of this trait of
this behavior and and how to make use of
it now let me say something about you
know conservative water use because now
we call it the plant water conservation
or water I'm trade rather than a delayed
wilting it they will impact yield and it
says part of the reason why you know um
under it you get these variable results
because the you know using water more
slowly means you're getting in co2 more
slowly you're growing more slowly and so
that's one reason in the second reason
is that drought is many things it
manifests in many ways depending on the
developmental stage and when it occurred
so you know this is what these
experiments look like this is from our
project it was multiple years the first
year we plan it up near the
raleigh-durham area clay soils lots of
rain that year no drought second year we
moved to these deep sandy soils in the
sand ridges in North Carolina the sand
hills research data to dry a terrible
year we you know everything did poorly
the Goldilocks story in our third
year we did pretty well we got you know
enough drought not too much here the
collaborators Thomson Claire usda-ars
scientists my master's thesis adviser
and Tommy Carter probably the preeminent
Jovian breeder in the US and here's the
Harvard crew we didn't manage to go down
there and pretend we were agricultural
lyst out in the field but but we didn't
waste the first three years of this of
this grant because we were working hard
in the lab to understand the basis of
this behavior this phenotype so that we
could help then the breeders try to
pinpoint its way because you've got to
bring these traits then back into high
yielding lines that are resistant that
pesticide so what we found and so I
thought was really interesting was where
the pointer is on this but anyway is
that the when we compared our pie this
is our will turn that's just another you
know reasonable yielding of similar age
soybean line so like a typical crop
plant as we increase what's called the
vapor pressure different so that's the
driving gradient you think of that is
the humidity going down the driving
gradient for evaporation out of the
leaves through the stomata that the
plants these holes that they get all
their co2 the the typical crop plant
just keeps on dry oh you know keeps its
stomata open the water just keeps piling
out and but in these conservative plants
when that when the humidity got too low
and then they shut their stomata now as
a student of wild plants this is exactly
what I expected plans to do it seemed
perfectly reasonable you wouldn't over
invest in water transport capacity but
throttle back but they my colleague Tom
Sinclair who was here at Harvard on
sabbatical he was shocked he's like
crops don't do this this is what crops
do so we have this sort of cross of
cultures there from the sort of by Allah
evolutionary biologists and the
agronomist but this was really useful
from water conserving trait because
these guys are throttling back there
semana at the time when they are least
efficient in the diffusional uptake of
co2 at vs water loss so they just cut
back then and they leave water in the
soil now a wild plant would never do
that leaving water in the soil is
useless because your neighbor takes it
but in a cropping situation it can lead
to more transpiration for more days
delayed wilting and that's in fact what
these plants do so but now we had some
understanding of the trait when we went
to step further though this is some
more complicated of stuff we do in the
lab to try to understand the hydraulic
basis of plants and basically we put
grow them in these these root pressure
chambers and we can override the
hydraulic effects of transpiration and
soil drawing we can basically null out
the effects of that and we can try did
we wanted to see where in the plant it
was sort of responding to this higher
transpiration 'old amande and what we
found it was not in this I LeMat
although the water transporting tubes
but downstream so what's downstream in a
plant it's in the leaf on the far end of
the veins before you get to where you
have whether evaporates so so like I not
you know I man acted in a kadai
mccreight I study the micro hydrology of
how water moves around in plants and
heat and evaporation and leaves but this
was really helpful because this now
gives us a way to develop screens for
this trait that don't involve growing
plants out over you know huge field you
can't do drought experiments in pots and
growth chambers it just that it's
useless and so now we knew something
more about these plants and it's been
very helpful so first of all we've been
able to because we understand the
behavior we can simulate the yield
response over in with a good soybean
physiology model and weather data for 50
years and she just looked at panel a
you'll see the fraction of years in
which this water conservation trait this
sort of conservative behavior at high
demand resulted in a yield increase it's
really you know it's not huge but it it
is in effect and then we've also
provided now tools for putting this this
this trait into high yielding
backgrounds and the seed distribution I
mean this stuff is now out there and
I'll just close with you this is just
off the web you know here's from pioneer
DuPont there aquamax so now they're
moving this trait they're looking for
this trait in other species of course
they're finding it right and I just have
this here I've got to circle that
advanced still model control because
it's not advance so with with breeding
for high yielding crops we got rid of
this more conservative behavior that is
you know inherent in in in natural
populations a natural selection leads to
that and we got rid of it for breeding
for high yields under agronomic
situations and now when we're sort of
thinking about the agricultural
footprint and yields under other
situations we find that this sort of
throttling back has some some value and
you can see that under you know under
some circumstances you get to lower
yield under certain rainfall you'll get
lower yield with this trait but if you
average over you know the the range of
conditions that in a farmer's going to
face this can be very helpful so all in
there